avec bruno chareyron ingénieur en
physique nucléaire responsable du
laboratoire de la criirad commission de
recherche et d'information indépendantes
sur la radioactivité
bonsoir monsieur merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france on vient de voir
les autorités japonaises qui veulent en
quelque sorte réhabiliter ces régions
touchées par cette catastrophe
une façon de tourner la page de dire que
ça va mieux mais je vous pose la
question avoue le spécialiste est ce que
selon vous est-ce que ça va vraiment
mieux
alors on peut pas dire que ça va bien en
tout cas puisque la catastrophe de
fukushima a répondu un métal radioactif
le césium 137 sur de très vastes
surfaces dans la préfecture de fukushima
mais aussi dans d'autres préfectures au
nord au sud et jusqu'à tokyo
et ce métal radioactif le césium 137 a
vu sa radioactivité décroître seulement
de 20% en neuf ans ça veut dire que la
radioactivité sur les zones les plus
impactés elle est toujours aujourd'hui
très importante et la décontamination
qui a été effectué pour l'instant par
les autorités japonaises n'est pas
satisfaisante
il n'est pas possible en fait de
décontaminer tous ces territoires on a
fait nos des contrôles dans la
préfecture de fukushima sur des lieux
pilote des maisons pilotes qui ont été
décontaminés c'est à dire que les les
responsables de ces opérations de
décontamination ont décapé la terre
autour de la maison
on est branché les arbres dans la forêt
en face on l'avait les toitures au
karcher mais ça ne suffit pas à ramener
le niveau de radioactivité à ce qu'il
était avant la catastrophe
et face à cette situation ce qu'ont fait
les autorités japonaises c'est tout
simplement augmenter les niveaux de
radioactivité admissible pour la
population en temps normal la dose
maximale annuelle admissible aller de un
millisieverts tu es après la catastrophe
de fukushima
elle a été passée à 20 millisieverts par
an ça veut dire que les autorités
acceptent que les gens subissent des
doses de radiation induisant un risque
cancer 20 fois supérieurs à ceux qui
auparavant était considéré comme un
maximum admissible et il faut bien
savoir que c'est ce qui se passera aussi
en france puisque ces normes
particulières qui sont mises en place
après les catastrophes nucléaires ce
sont des normes qui viennent de la
commission internationale de protection
radiologique sous la pression en
particulier d'experts français ça veut
dire que les autorités japonaises ont
mis en place des normes qui ne protège
pas correctement la santé des habitants
qui autorise de les faire revenir dans
des zones contaminées et il est très
probable qu'en france en cas de
catastrophe
on est à subir la même chose avec les
jeux olympiques qui vont se dérouler au
japon est ce qu'il n'ya pas justement
également des experts internationaux qui
peuvent avoir leur mot à dire
et justement ne pas laisser la seule
décision aux autorités japonaises parce
que les accusations en tout cas les
reproches ou les griefs que vous leur
portez sont quand même assez grave
si vous avez raison alors le problème
c'est que là on est dans des discours
d'experts
vous avez beaucoup d'experts
internationaux français japonais qui
vont vous dire que vivre avec ses
niveaux de radioactivité finalement
c'est acceptable mais ça c'est un
problème de niveau d'acceptation du
risque à partir du moment où on est sur
des risques qui sont liées à une
pollution radioactive des risques qui
sont subies par les citoyens ce que
devrait faire l'état c'est vraiment des
contaminés totalement les territoires et
si ce n'est pas possible à ce moment-là
indemniser les citoyens pour leur donner
des conditions décentes de vie dans des
lieux qui ne sont pas contaminés et ça
c'est pas ce qui s'est passé au moment
de fukushima vous avez des personnes qui
ont été laissés dans des zones
extrêmement radioactive on a pu le
constater nous mêmes sur le terrain
parce que dans ce cas là les autorités
préfèrent augmenter les niveaux de
radioactivité acceptable et ça
malheureusement s'est fait avec l'accord
d'un certain nombre d'experts
internationaux évidemment de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
mais aussi d'experts
de l'organisation mondiale de la santé
sachant qu' un accord très anciens entre
l'organisation mondiale de la santé et
la ja indique que l'organisation
mondiale de la santé ne peut pas se
prononcer sur des questions liées à la
radioactivité sans l'accord de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
dans tout le monde sait que cette agence
a pour objet la promotion du nucléaire
et non pas la protection de la santé des
populations
alors ça fait quand même neuf ans qu'a
eu lieu cette catastrophe de fukushima
est ce que justement ce que vous nous
dites est ce que il y a des moyens de le
constater sur les habitants est ce qu'il
y à des maladies des cancers d'autres
effets que l'on peut voir sur alors les
effets qui sont les plus évidents c'est
vraiment l'épidémie de cancers de la
thyroïde chez les personnes chez les
personnes par l'eau qui était jeune au
moment de la catastrophe là dessus il
n'y a pas de doute sur le fait qu'il ya
une augmentation extrêmement importante
des pathologies de la thyroïde et ce
n'est pas étonnant quand on voit les
doses de radiation qu'ont subis les
habitants de la région à la thyroïde par
l'inhalation dionne radioactifs et par
l'ingestion d'aliments contaminés par
deux lieux de radioactifs
sachant que ces tubes se fixe ensuite
sur la thyroïde qu'il irradie après la
difficulté c'est que toute une série de
pathologies qu'elles soient des cancers
ou qu'elles soient des maladies
cardiovasculaires par exemple
n'apparaîtront qu'au fur et à mesure des
années et des décennies
ça veut dire que pour tirer un réel
bilan de cette catastrophe
et c'est le même problème avec
tchernobyl il faut suivre l'état de
santé des populations pendant des
décennies or ça ne sera pas fait au
japon puisque les protocoles de
surveillance qui ont été mis en place en
particulier sous le contrôle de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique qui
était un organisme pro nucléaires ces
protocoles sont insatisfaisants d'abord
ce ne sont que les populations de la
préfecture de fukushima qui ont un suivi
or la contamination est allé bien
au-delà des limites de la préfecture de
fukushima
deuxièmement c'est surtout
sont les pathologies thyroïdiennes qui
sont suivies et non pas l'état sanitaire
général or l'exposition à la
radioactivité peut avoir des effets sur
l'ensemble du corps humain sur les
fonctions cardio vasculaires digestive
neurologiques etc
et puis ce suivi je donne tout sur les
personnes ou qui tu es jeune
au moment de la catastrophe et non pas
sur toute la population
ça veut dire que on n'aura probablement
jamais un bilan sérieux rigoureux et
exhaustif des conséquences sanitaires à
long terme de la catastrophe de
fukushima
autre dommage important de cette
catastrophe
on en parle souvent ces lots contaminés
une quantité massive d'eau est stocké
dans l'enceinte du site et cette eau est
souvent rejetés dans les océans qu'elle
risque selon vous pour les santé
publique alors par rapport aux problèmes
de l'eau contaminée d'abord il faut
rappeler que la catastrophe de fukushima
en 2011 a été l'événement qui a rejeté
le plus de radioactivité dans l'océan
pacifique
pratique hors de toute l'histoire à
l'époque deuxièmement ces rejets dans
l'océan se poursuivre
quasiment en permanence ne serait ce que
parce que lorsqu'il pleut la
contamination qui a été déposée par voie
aérienne sur les sols cette
contamination et ré entraîner vers le
milieu marin et puis troisièmement il y
a en permanence une diffusion de
radioactivité depuis les sous sols de la
centrale de fukushima vers l'océan
malgré tout une série de barrières qui
ont été mises en place par tepco pour
essayer de limiter cette migration
et puis en fait enfin comme vous l'avez
dit il y a le problème des eaux qui sont
extrêmement radioactive qui doivent être
pompés en permanence sous la centrale et
qui sont régénérer en permanence par le
fait qu'il faut rajouter de l'eau en
permanence pour refroidir les réacteurs
accidentés une eau qui se contaminent et
qui vient augmenter en permanence le
stock d'eau contaminée astro à stocker
et comme tepco
indiquent qu'ils vont bientôt être en
limite des capacités d'entreposage des
eaux contaminées
telco fait pression sur le gouvernement
japonais pour avoir l'autorisation
prochainement de rejeter ces eaux
contaminée dans l'océan pacifique alors
ce sont des eaux qui ont été
partiellement des contaminés mais qui
reste tout de même contaminé par un
certain non radioactif dans l'eau
tritium le strontium 90 diodes 129 cas
une période de 16 millions d'années et
donc ces eaux ne devrait pas pouvoir
être rejetés dans l'océan pacifique
mais quand on est confronté à une
catastrophe nucléaire toutes les règles
habituelles de protection de la santé
des populations et de l'environnement
sont violé les règles par rapport aux
doses subies par les personnes ont été
changés et c'est le cas aussi pour les
eaux merci beaucoup aux bruno chareyron
ingénieur en physique nucléaire
responsable du laboratoire de la criirad
d'avoir été avec nous on dirait